I want the left half to shout and cheer.
Okay, that was pathetic. I now want the right half to shout and cheer a lot louder than that.
Okay, left half. Can you beat the right half? Off you go?
Okay. That’s integrity. I like that.
[Music]
Hello everyone and welcome to Octothorpe,  the podcast for science fiction and science fiction fandom.
I'm John Coxon. I'm Alison Scott. Liz is… we've got a placard for Liz but she's not here.
All will be revealed. So we have an item of business. We have an item of business. It's long and pointy.
Oh, yes, so, yeah. So do you want to bring it up? And get your cameras at the ready because this
is a photo opportunity. We need to also arrange you for reasons that we'll see. It's Nicholas,
come around this way. Nicholas, come around this side. This is an on stage, off stage.
So for listeners at home it is April Fool's Day on the day we record and the chapter art for this
episode is a wonderful not a Hugo which is not being presented to us, which we are not accepting.
And it is not being presented to us by our stunt Liz Nicholas Whyte.
Oh, oh no, it really is a real Hug–. It is not a real Hugo.
That is fantastic. It is absolutely remarkable. It's a marvelous art. So for people on the radio,
you can have a look if you see it but I'm going to say a little, oh yeah no, all the ways we are
not allowed to hold it. So one of the jokes that didn't get get into the newsletter was “there is no polite way
to polish a Hugo”. So we are very excited to be one of the first people to touch Glasgow 2024's
Hugo base design. I think you've announced that? Esther MacCallum-Stewart is in the front row of
this podcast and she is now making faces like… She's hiding under the table. There is a Glasgow
chair under the table. If found please return to Ops. By Hugo based designer Sara Felix.
Can I talk to the object? And also by Vincent Villafranca. So I'm going to give you a description
of this for the radio but so they have taken an act– which I think is an actual Peter Weston style.
It has been, it has been, it has been, there really is no polite way to talk about this Hugo. They've taken a real
Peter Weston style Hugo and they have… rocket, because it's obviously not a Hugo. I need to say
that. So Esther is that it is a what? A tartan rocket. A tartan rocket and they have dipped it.
Like they've wrapped it like when you get one of those taxis that advertises Just Eats.
Yes and I think the question on the question on everyone's mind is which local businesses will
be being advertised on the real Hugos. So obviously they've said she's under the table again listeners.
We've sent her under the table again. We're not nice people. And so they've dipped it in the
landing zone tartan which is the actual official tartan as mentioned in the authority of tartans
and the tartan, I don't know the tartan times or whatever it's called on that. So yes Nicholas do
you want to talk a little bit as our guest about how this came to be? So the base by
Villafranca who designed the San José and it is exceptionally beautiful. It has three armadillos
on it and some books. Yes and we now need to let our guest Nicholas get a word in.
So you will have observed, you have observed that there are three lovely well read armadillos
here. Two of them, in homage to the Duke of Wellington or rather to his statue in Glasgow,
are wearing traffic cones and the third is simply piloting the starship as one does and on the sides
you will see two haggises. Yes. One in dormant state and one in full flying state with its
ceremonial toupee. Curled around the back are an acorn…
So what is the significance of the acorn? The acorn and the two cats are personal to the designers.
Oh so the acorn is a Villafranca thing. It's a Villafranca thing. And the cat is for
for Sara. I believe that's a sign. Sara could have been here but couldn't quite make it so
it's a shame. Texas is quite far but yeah. On the the plaque on the front says very clearly
Glasgow 2024 Happy April Fool's Day, First of April 2024 because this is not a Hugo and we're
not presenting it to anybody and underneath inscribed – oof – in the base is the ceremonial inscription
‘there can be only one’. And this is the only one that there will ever be and this is as you said
quite correctly Alison, this is a thing of total beauty. It is absolutely magnificent.
I would say that I've seen a lot of real Hugo designs and this is actually better than several
of them. I would agree with that. More stylish, more in keeping with the sanctity of the Hugo brand.
So the actual Hugo base for Glasgow will be quite different but will be also very, very good.
The listeners can't see the immense look of pleasure on Nicholas's face when he says that but
this is a happy, happy man. So yes. Liz, Liz Batty who I think has written to us a couple of times in the
past points out the Vincent Villafranca also designed the 2013 Hugo base as well as collaborating
with Sara on the 2018 base. There will be pictures as I say in the show notes but it is extremely
beautiful and I assume it will be on display in Glasgow. I believe that's the case because it
would be a great shame if people didn't get to see it. But yes, but yes Nicholas hello welcome.
Hey John, hey Alison, thank you for having me. Thank you for coming on the podcast. We are
absolutely delighted. You have been on our list of possible stunt Lizzes for some time. Yes,
for once I'm in the right place at the right time. Or am I. So what do you want me to say?
Just tell us how marvellous our podcast is for a bit.
Well as you know I'm kind of constrained on that one. Yes yes.
So the... That's right. Yes obviously. He cannot comment. I just wonder if you've got any news about
the podcast that you'd like to share with listeners before I say something about that.
We are coming to you from Eastercon, Levitation and the Hugo finalists were announced immediately
after the opening ceremony and amongst very worthy finalists we are one of them and this is very
exciting. We would like to thank everyone who nominated us. It is a thrill to be sure.
Oh Jt! For people who are listening on the podcast later. Jt has worked out he could
live stream the Discord chat to the big screen in the room. What could possibly go wrong?
I think we probably should say a little bit about our stunt Liz. So we're absolutely delighted
that our stunt list this week because Liz is in Thailand is Nicholas Whyte but he is also the
division head for WSFS for the 2024 Worldcon and I think probably we have to say the disclaimer
now that actually other podcasts are available. Yes absolutely. And then I’m also the administrator
the Hugo Awards. And he’s also the administrator of the Hugo Awards. A separate job and it's all coming together in perfect
harmony. So yes and the Hugo finalist announcement went without a hitch. It was all very smooth
and unstressful. It seemed very good. There is a...
The chair of the Glasgow Worldcon is now making a… chair fort. Yes. So Nicholas how has...
So this is a swan thing though. I'm going to say from my vantage point in the audience
it looked to me like the Hugo announcement went off incredibly well. Yes. I had in fact… That was what I
was cueing up. I had in fact been told by a number of people in the bar the previous night
that things might not be quite as perfectly, perfectly smooth as they appeared. And
I appreciate that. Of course what you see is the swans serenely gliding along the surface of
the water and you do not see the little feet paddling subsurface and because it's the Hugos it's a
swan with three legs not with two. And also, also all of the swans in Glasgow for Glasgow 2024 will
have been dipped in the tartan. Yes it's not a white swan but a tartan swan.
Are Glaswegian swans owned by the King? I'm a Belgian so I cannot answer that question.
Oh I will say this is off topic but fortunately we've been very on topic.
But I knew Nicholas has... Nicholas has excellent ribbons which have a joke about Belgium on them
and I could tell people who had bumped into Nicholas by observing the ribbons. It was like
ooh you've seen Nicholas because people had a ribbon. It says on it that's a bit
undramatic isn't it? So the reason that the ribbon says that's a bit undramatic isn't it?
This is a Doctor Who quote those of you who know me may know that I have watched one or two
Doctor Who episodes in my life and in the episode Time Crash in which Peter Davison encounters David
Tennant, the fifth and tenth doctors meet each other, Peter Davison complains that the collision of the
two TARDISes could blow a hole in the space time continuum the exact size of Belgium and then he
goes on to say that's a bit undramatic isn't it? So I printed these up for Gallifrey One where
indeed you and I met each other most recently John and it's a little silhouette of the map of
Belgium with the slogan that's a bit undramatic isn't it? So I have many more back in my room I've
only got one left in my hand but you can come and talk to me afterwards. We had dinner and Nicholas
knew that, well Nicholas was aware of the nominations and kept a straight face and it was very frustrating
because we were watching him like a hawk for hints, and there were none. At that point that was mid-February
so we still had some way to go in voting but I could see the way things were going but it was good.
But yeah I'll have more to say about the dinner when we get to picks actually.
Okay fair enough. But to say a bit more about the Hugo process the video was just beautifully done
so absolutely props to Jt for his and Meg who, Meg McDonald who were really at the coalface of
putting it together. We had frustrations we had one very late withdrawal which meant that those
slides had to be rewritten and re-recorded. I was told he pulled out just in time.
You're referring...
I was told thas Bigolas Dickolas pulled out just in time.
I have been told that by multiple people who've been not named.
It is true that Bigolas Dickolas pulled out but was not perhaps the last to do so but...
I had not heard, actually had heard that. I'm pretending that I had not heard that because it is better or
it was good that way. But we had the the the great assistance of Sophia Xue in Shanghai who recorded
half of the categories and the withdrawals category. She is of course a native Mandarin speaker but is
as you will have heard from the video fluent in English and because we had so many Chinese names
in the categories I felt it was possibly better to get a native Mandarin speaker to do it rather
than have me mangling their names in probably saying something quite offensive without necessarily
intending to which is rather easy to do in some languages. So that, that went very well. We had
great participation from Glasgow's team and from the special guests. I hope you all particularly
enjoyed the three black halflings. That was a very good... Yes indeed that was great.
And the presenter who I think probably very few people were expecting to see was Jeffrey Gernsback,
the great grandson… Yes that was a delight. Tell me who Jeffrey Gernsback is. So Jeffrey Gernsback
lives quite close to Chicago and he’d contacted me in advance of the Chicon Worldcon to say that
he'd hoped he could make it but unfortunately it wasn't going to be possible. So when I heard this I
said you know how much money would that take? What can we do? How can we get you there?
It wasn't possible logistically in the end but we stayed in touch. He sent me that lovely photograph.
He was born about eight months before his great grandfather died. So there's a lovely family
photograph which you'll see in the video of a very aged Hugo Gernsback, his son, Jeff's grandfather,
his grandson Jeff's father and Jeff's aunt is in the picture as well. So that was just very very
nice. He was absolutely keen to do it and so we're staying in touch as to how we can get the Gernsback
family perhaps a bit more recognised in the Hugo process than has been the case. I don't think
there'd really been much connection in the years since Hugo Gernsback died which I think was 1967.
Oh it was very cool. And yeah it's like seven seconds of participation but it's seven seconds
more than we've had in 50 something years. We have it. So one of the
the Fancast category was introduced by Tammy Coxen and she posted to say that she had chosen
Fancast because she was hoping that she would get to read our nomination out. So hello Tammy,
that was very sweet. Thank you very much indeed. And she did it behind her cocktail bar and presented
the Glasgow Gimlet as part of the introduction which was great. But there are a lot of lovely
little flourishes and I thought like I'm not trying to be facetious like from the outside it seemed
like everything went off without a hitch. And obviously like you say the three legs of the
mutant swan frantically paddling. We mentioned Bigolas Dickolas for listeners who don't know
and we'll get on to the people who accepted their finalist slots later but there were five
people who declined. Martha Wells for System Collapse which is I believe the latest Murderbot novel.
Hai Ya for the far north. Bigolas Dickolas, Natasha Bardon in Best Editor Long Form and
Camestros Felapton in Best Fan Writer and I just want to say Bigolas Dickolas is a good egg
because I think that was the right call. There have been people who accepted for things that I
would rather had not been on the finalist slate and I'm thinking of you Chris. You know who you are
But I think it's very classy to decline because it's a funny joke but. Yeah. It was quite difficult
to track Bigolas Dickolas down. Tell us about how you looked for Bigolas Dickolas.
It was actually I mean I don't think this needs to be a secret it was it was Amal El-Mortar
one of the authors of This is How We Lose the Time War – Oh okay that's – Who made the connection but I think I think
Bigolas Dickolas being a bit outside the community sent me a rather curious message saying
are you the Nicholas Whyte who Amal El-Mortar tells me I need to contact and is this about the Hugo
Awards because if so I don't want to be in it. If however you're contacting me for some other
reason please accept my apologies for the tone of that first paragraph. So I mean that is classy.
I agree. I think that is classy. And it's important to communicate direct. I mean I think so we you had
five five withdrawals at the end and I think three people that decline three people that um
three.. Three that we had to disqualify although one of those had had been nominated separately in
a different category for which they were eligible. So to to talk about those quickly the three that
were disqualified were all Chinese. One of them was a novel where the copyright date was December
2023 but my intense research in the Chinese science fiction community made it pretty clear that it
wasn't in the shops or available and that even the author had not had a copy until 2024 which means
that under the Hugo Rules it is not eligible and then we had two successful nominees in the
Fancast category but and it made me research the professional criteria because a Fancast
must be a Fancast and not professional and these were both in fact professional productions and
they they accepted that when I explained the rules to them. I will um I will look forward to getting
the Hugo longlist which I think I'm getting I'm getting at the party this year right which has
as God intended um I'll look forward to seeing which of those ones would have knocked us off the
ballot. No comment. Yes that is entirely fair and I think there was worry there was there was
there was commentary when when Glasgow announced the tack they were going to take with um declaring
who had declined and who was ineligible. I think they was worried it would over shit um over shit.
That will probably be likely… It would shit all over the other finalists but I don't think they
felt shut on at all. What's your opinion Nicholas? The feedback has been positive as all I would say
but I mean it's it's a fair point a couple of those who declined kind of said why do you need to even
make it public that we were involved with the ballot in in any way um to which the answer is that
people people voted for you and they need to know what happened to those votes and unfortunately
from that perspective the Hugos belong to the voters they don't actually belong to the finalists
and I think that's a really important principle that um you know there's a limit to how far voters
wishes should be ignored or not reported and I'm very committed to making sure that voters know
what has happened and can see what's been done with their votes. That's fantastic actually thank you
and I think so we always used we've done this we've had this transparency for a very long time we
we we're just going to draw a a gentle veil over the 2023 Hugos for the purpose of this podcast
but we've had this very long standing tradition of releasing this data after the after the ceremony
but I think bringing it forward is quite a bold move from Glasgow and I think you probably did
have to do that as a result of what happened last year. The the secret that not many people have
noticed is we actually did this my first year administering the Hugos in 2017 in Finland and we
actually published that year we published withdrawals and disqualifications. Yeah but you did it in
Finnish so nobody noticed it. That's fair that's fair and I remember I remember recording the thing
at Helsinki airport and thinking no one's going to remember this and indeed you didn't so
That’s fair, we have a we do have a terrible memory I mean I speak myself. We weren't doing the
podcast. I will say since we started the podcast our memories have been absolutely
infalliable yes no I mean if you say oh you mentioned this on episode 23 we will definitely
remember that isn't that right John. There is there was a there was a hilarious statement made… there is a
there is a discord for fans of the WSFS business meeting and I am in it as a sort of
person who would like the business meeting to go away so what’s tha,t a bad actor in that discord
but um but there was someone who said Alison said this on this episode and Alison said, no I have
never said that in my life it was definitely Liz and then I checked the transcripts and it was
Alison and she said it verbatim how they transcribed it and I was like no Alison you did say that
it was only two episodes ago as well it wasn't like ever so you know um so yes so Nicholas you
you are… someone has posted in the chat saying you know almost as much about the Hugos as Liz
so that is high praise. It is high praise she's probably more upstate with her recent research than
I am I actually want before we move off the topic of the Hugo nominations I wanted to say something
more about them which is that there are quite a lot of to my mind good ones I know that Nicholas
can't comment apart from say all Hugo… he loves all his finalists equally deeply and does not pick
favorites but I was delighted to see some of the people on the um list do and were you yeah most
people were delighted to see there was one person in fan artist I was like I don't know
Really sorry España. it's okay it's okay she was not hilarious is España was distracted at
that point so she's gonna have to listen to the episode to find out the burn um but no so so for
those who don't know Alison uh Alison my learned co-host and España my lovely wife were both
nominated in fan artist and obviously a big big booster of that and and España and Anna in the
chat have both said they're all good finalists Brent and that is the official, that's
the official Glasgow line I think and you might also be the official Octothorpe line we'll probably have a
we'll have to think about it over the next two weeks and think about the things that we are
tragically sad were not nominated and talk about sorry we the things that we are tragically
sad were not finalists um I will say that there were three categories where there was like one
vote in it at the end yeah whether the the next but one candidate would have been on with one
three two years ago two years ago three years ago three years ago twenty four years ago do I hear
five years 2021 I was I was asked to do some work for DisCon III by Nicholas
and um and I said you know this might be really difficult if if Octothorpe was nominated we
were a very new podcast at the time and he said well you haven't been but you know you should make sure
that you all three of you and all three of your partners nominated because yeah you were only off it by
by one vote we had a frank discussion because obviously self-promotion is gosh
but um there was a conversation where we're like Alison was like well obviously I didn't
nominate us and I was like if we don't nominate us with how can we expect anyone else to nominate
us and I'm like I'm British and you don't vote for yourself and I have been persuaded actually by um
by John who said if you don't buy two things really one is John who said if if you don't self-promote
then then people from other countries who shall be nameless who were brought up to self-promote
from an early age will get all the awards and British people who would rather die in a
ditch than say that their own stuff is good will never get any of the awards and then two more things
three things sorry the second thing was the secret zoom am I allowed to talk about the secret zoom
well we yes no but we should introduce it we should do that as the last thing and we should
segue oh the second thing or the third thing because the second thing
Emily Inkpen um I'm going to credit for the person who alerted me to this idea suggested in
the BSFA discord you if you're a member of the BSFA should be in that discord it's now quite good
um but she suggested that British people should find a buddy who really really like you like their
stuff and they really really like your stuff um hello España and and you should and you should
go and big up their stuff and they should big up your stuff and then it won't feel so bad and on
that topic everyone should rank first in best related work uh all these worlds reviews and essays
by Niall Harrison. Niall has joined Esther, Niall is under the table, Esther is in front of him they are
both um so what we're saying here is Esther and Niall are under the table together.
Niall’s quite tall so whereas it was quite easy for Esther to hide under the table
Neil's quite tall but Esther isn’t, i'm not like yet but so easy for Esther to hide under
that now there's so much chapter off this episode now i think i think i think i think
Emily's idea in the BSFA Discord is very good and i think the thing i will say is you don't
necessarily have self-promote, but i have started trying to boost other British people who don't
self-promote because i do think if if no one promotes anyone in Britain that is a shame because
there are some good things here can you give me an example of something you've been promoting
Alison Scott for fan artists you should also rank her high at the top of your ballot
Alison is now under the table
well you asked that's not that uncommon at an Eastercon actually um but the other thing that
happened Nicholas, Nicholas is someone who cares i think quite a lot about the Hugo Awards
i think it's uncontroversial to say and one of the things that Glasgow has done is they actually
had a zoom call that all the finalists were invited to that had sort of people talking about
basically what it's like to be nominated how you might want to self-promote, there were talks
for various people Mary Robinette Kowal came to talk to everyone and it was really nice
um so yeah Nicholas what brought that about like i think it's a great idea but it was an evolution
i i had hoped that we would have a public town hall about the whole Hugo process
and then there were certain personnel changes in our team which meant that the work was
the work was shared a bit more intensely between those of us who who were who remained on it
and we just didn’t have  the bandwidth to do an open public town hall before the
nomination before voting closed um that still meant that when we brought on um our ace crack
Hugo finalist liaison head Randy Shepherd,  passed this idea onto him – former Worldcon chair Randy
Shepherd, yeah a former Worldcon chair Randy Shepherd and the first thing he said was ‘well
let's let's just do this for the Hugo finalists’ at this point time was rather
was getting very very tight and the invitations went out went out with less than 48 hours notice
which is tighter than i would have liked it to be but you deal with the circumstance you have
and in the event i thought i'm glad you thought it went well i have the sense it was going well as
well. We thought it was delicious we we spent an entire hour in Discord with a list of the
participants in that zoom chat working out who must have been nominated for what Hugo.
yes we we We started with there was one participant on the zoom whose name on zoom was Gong
Wandering Earth producer and we thought maybe that meant Wandering Earth II might have been
nominated so we started with that. And then I got a DM on the zoom from Geri Sullivan at which
point i completely lost it because i am… unlike unlike Nicholas i do not have to be non-partisan
i am absolutely thrilled that Geri has been nom.. uh is a finalist for Idea which is
not only is it a proper real fanzine that is, like you can actually get a print copy of
but also I’m in it. I want to ask i want to ask Nicholas a question from the audience
is it a greater honor in your opinion to be the Hugo administrator or the stunt Liz
feel free not to answer if it will cause an international incident. I mean I think this the
sixth time i've been involved with the Hugos but it's probably the one and only time in my life
that i will be a stunt Liz so it's just impossible to compare the two experiences.
excellent and it was it was Stuart. thank you Stuart for that thank you Stuart for that
not all the questions. somebody in the chat was taking was laying bets on who the stunt Liz would
be and i'm just going to say one of the people he suggested was somebody who has been stunt Liz before
and that's not going to happen and the other person he suggested was the number one
person who will never ever be stunt Liz because she keeps turning us down so you know. just just
to finish on the the finalists zoom we will also do, the public town hall model has not gone away
and we hope that we will do public town halls on all three of the areas of the WSFS division
for Glasgow which is to say the not just the Hugos but also site selection and the business meeting
so that's really and that that public i'm really looking forward to public town halls on the
business meeting that that's me because that that will go really that will go really smoothly and
there won't be any controversy versus all sounds will it be okay for me to turn up to the town halls
on the business meeting wearing a robe and having a bell and just shouting "shame"
i mean i'm not in charge of code of conduct questions but
we're has been pointed out in the chat that we said all BSFA members should join the BSFA discord
but in fact it is open to all so everyone should join the BSFA discord and it's good yeah i'd
also everyone should join the BSFA because you know it's the BSFA because it's good too yes it's
also good but the BSFA awards have this charming thing going back to something you mentioned earlier
where you're not actually allowed to vote for yourself and i think that's really cute i think
it's i think it's a bit silly as well but it's very cute the other thing i was going to say about
the um yes but we're British so obviously one of the things about Britain let's see you don't vote
for yourself proud Belgian here traditionally so one of the things about the zoom was it in that
zoom i think this is a thing i'm allowed to talk about that they had Kevin Lampe talking
to us who is a very high powered PR and he talked to us about how the we should say
in every sentence did i mention that i was a hugo finalist i mean i am not in any way exaggerating
he was on a zoom for hugo finalist and i should say at this point that i am a hugo finalist and
he said in every sentence you say to anybody you should say that you are a hugo finalist and i've
been trying to do though i couldn't do that but i can't i mean it was quite hard just doing it
for the length of that comment. My students are going to get really fed up in my lectures.
So it was by British standards i think i found that presentation a bit much. I think people who have
been outside the system and are for whom it's genuinely a new experience just like a bit of guidance
that they're not jumping and it's something i have heard from first-time finalists previously
that they would have liked a bit more advice as to how to handle it and to tell people well
there's two there's two things here which is firstly we're old hands now but secondly none of us have
any real skin in the game. It's purely egoboo for us whereas like if you are an author there's like
actual career considerations involved and so yeah i think having that kind of guidance i mean for
us we were like well you know we might tell people we're a Hugo finalist and then we might never
mention it again and it's fine but i can see it for nominated for professional things. yes for
someone who's at the very very start of their career and i was about to say who are professionally
nominated but i don't think that's a career i don't i hope that nobody was yes exactly so so
Bob Shaw um who i really quite adored um had to kind of wrestle his publishers to the ground to
stop them putting Hugo Winner on his books when he had won the Hugo for best fanzine and best
fan writer and and i'm like oh oh and but he but i think times have changed and i actually know at
least one author who has who has won in a fan category and then put it on their books now and i think
probably that's something that people do more now. yeah that's where we admire the modesty of
Peter Capaldi who is in fact a winner of an Oscar but not as an actor is he what was he what did he
win for he won best animated film quite already in his career he did an animation film about
France Kafka oh i i wrote this is slightly off topic but the it's called google it for her John
google it for me it's funny but i went to the the name of the film… Soph says in discord if you or
anyone you know has been affected by a hugo award nomination there is support available
and i thought that was very good. Fair. Hello Soph. DC says it's “Franz Kafka’s ’It’s a wonderful
life’ “ that's the one yep thank you dc they there was a um the Guardian had a profile of Peter
Capaldi you can take all that other stuff out, John, in the lightly edit um the Guardian had a
profile of Franz Kafka where – of god – the Guardian had a profile of Peter Capaldi in which Liz is
going to tell us what was in it. Or indeed Alison, When Alison’s finished…
The Guardian had a profile of Peter Capaldi when it mentioned his short film
‘Franz Kafka's “It's a wonderful life”’ but it put the link and the quotes around It's a wonderful life
and not around ‘Franz Kafka's “it's a wonderful life” ‘ so so i wrote to the guardian's corrections
editor as i do every, about twice a week and said you have made this trivial error but it made me
laugh which ones like that do because they they apparently it doesn't make you laugh though… things
so there are occasional times when Alison says things on the podcast and there is
silence and she’s like ‘but you're not laughing’ and me and Liz are like what? So i'm not i'm not saying
i self-promote but i think i may be funnier in my head than i actually am.
yeah um that was better inside my head before it came out. yeah so what we thought of the Eastercon.
What did we think about the Eastercon? Yay i thought it was good yep and that was the Eastercon
Time for picks no come on so so this was my Eastercon where i wasn't going to do anything
i was just going to have a really relaxing weekend. I said I’d do a newsletter shift and I’d do a bit
of work on the fan funds, and at four fifteen yesterday afternoon i sat down with Kari and
Kari Sperring and Aliette de Bodard, and had and realized that for the next 38 minutes I had nowhere
to go, nothing to do, nothing i felt i should have done but hadn’t and then and then normal
reality kicked in since i've been back to the too many things to do and not enough time.
Have you been busy? I had a lot of fun um as has been mentioned we did the
Hugo announcement on friday immediately after the opening ceremony and i'd been we had decided we
were going to do it on that day three years ago so it was the culmination of a three-year plan
to which many many people contributed um so that was big, um and i'm afraid i spent
saturday kind of decompressing um but uh i've been to i've been on a couple of panels i've been to a
bunch more i've had huge fun in the dealers’ room expensively but there we are um also one thing i
think i've spoken to more new people who have not been to an Eastercon before here than has been the
case previously and i don't know whether it's because there genuinely are more new people or maybe
it's just that I just look more friendly since i grew a beard. I wonder because for those those who don't
know this is a smaller Eastercon than usual which is which is often the case in a year with the
uk Worldcon because Worldcons are expensive, Eastercons are expensive a lot of people will choose
the Worldcon over the Eastercon but I wonder at conventions where there are fewer fans it's easier
to meet the new fans because you can just see more people as a percentage of the convention because
I have met more people this year than I have since the pandemic I think and it's been really fun I had
lots of lovely conversations with people I’ve not really talked to before and they were all great
and I did not mention to any of them that I had a podcast or that it was on the Hugo Ballot
because that is how I roll Sorry you're supposed I understand from Kevin Lampe is that i'm supposed
to put it in every sentence did you not do that um no i did not. What do we think of the venue i now
I’m quite shocked about this because um I was very skeptical I quite like it okay so actually i'm
going to classify this i quite I think the Telford International Center is lovely it's a very good
sized for an Eastercon we could grow quite a bit and still use it because there's another programme
space exactly the same size as this one so you although you'd have a little bit of walking between
the two you could definitely you could put a large Eastercon into the space and this is lovely and
if it were anywhere other than Telford. I do love Nandos so i quite like Telford because there is a
nandos.There are yeah I was going to say as long as as long as your idea of a nice place to eat
at an Eastercon is a low to mid-range chain restaurant that will serve you quickly like say
Nandos I feel like Telford is actually pretty good for that, there's basically a dozen of them
within about two minutes walk of the convention center and that's been quite nice.
If you actually want a proper meal i understand that taxi cabs are available
and there's some very good places to go to in them i've been i've been to two of them i'll
recommend two of them. The Ugly Duckling which is a pub on the far side of Telford and the 1840 restaurant
which is a converted Methodist church about halfway to the Ugly Duckling fair enough so i would have
thought if i were so if i had a if if everyone who has said to me this weekend that they're thinking
about voting bidding for an Eastercon and they've got some really good ideas and if they did the
Eastercon they would do it in a particular way that is is not the way that i have done it or that
this year's done it or anything but they've got they've got strong ideas and they want to be an
Eastercon chair if every single one of those people bids an Eastercon we will never be short
of bids ever again we do have a question you mentioned that there are taxi cabs available
and David Bamford in the discord has asked can you eat taxi cabs though Emily Emily January says
if you're not a coward and Meg Macdonald says are they deep fried so there are these are the
questions we need answering so this is a Glasgow thing so is there deep fried food available in
Glasgow? No there's none. Fish and chips never made it to Scotland no no Meg has promised to take me
for deep fried pizza when i'm in Glasgow. Meg has never had it. You did, you promised! Stuart says pizza
crunch and i say pizza crunch we all say pizza crunch so um but no i'm very looking forward to
Glasgow there's lots of great food in Glasgow. Glasgow has a vibrant food culture
a few so so obviously we don't have the audience mic’ed so i mean we do have the audience mic’ed but i
am just going to repeat for the benefit of the audience what Esther just said which is that Glasgow
has a vibrant food culture and i can confirm that because I have now eaten a deep fried
Mars Bar. that's fair so i haven't actually i we split it between four of us which was plenty
and there's still still too much Esther came came to shout at us and España said ‘she can be
lured out’ so these are strategies and Bridget notes that McVities do do a chocolate bar called
Taxi so hurrah. And has provided a photo. that's a fair point. i want to i want to quickly give my
thoughts on the venue which is i like it um we're going to talk more about this in the next episode
uh because we always do a deeper dive into the Eastercon when we're not being drunk,
tired and excitable um but what i would say and i've said this to a couple of people i've seen in
the convention up to now is if you are someone who has mobility issues i would love you to write
us a letter of comment before we discuss this Eastercon sort of very much to like to hear
your thoughts on the access because there was a big conversation about that beforehand and i would
like to know how people found it who attended the con so far i've heard nothing but good things
but i would be interested to know whether that is accurate or representative before i shoot my
mouth out on the radio. i just want to say in the discord Bridget Bradshaw has suggested that people
are coming to talk to me because they think there may be crumbs and snacks hidden in my beard and
i mean you're welcome to all come and have a good look afterwards.
Well some of you are i i have been told by a secret informant who is my ex-husband
that the venue has planning permission for a second lift and it just needs to find
the pennies stored down it's it's um you know the back of it's sofa so if we bring the Eastercon
here they might again they might find it again. i'd be happy to come i think this this venue has
been great really and i don't think telford's telford wasn’t… you know they say they're in within
three hours travel of 90 percent of the uk population um, and that's basically true as long as you're
not trying to travel on Maundy Thursday or by train.
Picks. So, Nicholas as our guest, would you like to have a pick yeah my picks are both dr who related
excellent inevitably it does sound like you're on brand um it's i know it's utterly uncharacteristic
one of them is just a general sequence of books about Doctor Who stories called the Black Archive and
what they do is every month they take a different story either from old who or from you who and
they've also done Scream of the Shalka and the TV movie with them with with Paul McGann which
can fall between them and they have somebody just doing an in-depth dive in a scholarly way usually
in the space of 80 to 120 pages just looking at how the story came to be what it really means
what what how it ties into wider cultural issues wider historical issues um i've i've read the first
60 of the 80 or so that have been published so far and of those 60 maybe three or four have been
duds and that's quite a good strike rate for any series of any series of books. The other one also
dr who related um john you'll recall we had dinner in Los Angeles um a month or so ago with yourself
and España, and with Simon Guerrier, a doctor who fiction writer and writer of many other things as
well. He’s just published a biography of David Whittaker who was the first script editor of Doctor
Who back in the early 1960s and wrote several of the classic stories of the Hartnall and Troughton
eras including the two Troughton Dalek stories um very interesting character
who managed to um pass through his career without leaving much of an imprint in people who knew him
they're they're kind of uh people are asked about meetings that he was clearly at because he's in
the he's in the minutes and they can't remember that he was there a bit like the Bob Shaw character
who's a human neutrino and uh nobody remembers who he was and you know poor David Whittaker died in
1980 at the age of 51 if he'd lived another five years he would have become one the celebrities of
the burgeoning Doctor Who fan culture that appeared around about that time but he didn't
poor guy and I got the sense that um he'd had an internal career at the BBC, decided to go freelance
and discovered that nobody knew who he was, which is an awful shame. so it's uh it's it's quite a
thick book but i found it very interesting because he goes um Simon goes into the um wider tv culture
and theatrical culture and general um issues with how British society functions at the time
so i strongly recommend that. I have discovered recently that i bloody love history books
especially very specific nerdy history books so that sounds very good this is this is pretty
specific and pretty nerdy yeah yeah it sounds very very good i might have to look that up like that
one on the space program? Yeah that was great, and it was very helpful in my uh panel on Saturday
which feared much more into the geopolitics of space than i think i was expecting it to so i was
very glad i had interesting things to say about that. So DC makes the absolutely accurate point that
David Whittaker was omitted from the drama documentary An Adventure in Space and Time. His role was actually
merged with several other characters so yeah absolutely fair point. Alison, do you have a pick?
um i was wondering if you wanted to go first actually. I do have a pick. i'm going to pick something
on the bleeding edge of culture which is a six episode television series from 2004 and it is
Garth Marenghi’s Dark Place oh tell us about your cosplay john. so yes um on on saturday uh
España and I cosplayed characters from Garth Marengi’s Dark Place i was uh Dr Rick Dagless MD
um España was Madeleine Wool uh who plays Liz Asher in the show so this is a um tv show where the
conceit is quite dr who e in that the conceit is it was so horrific at the time it was made that it was
banned on British television and it wasn't shown anywhere in the world except for Peru
and um they found it in a cupboard and decided to rebroadcast it on Channel Four with talking heads
and like historical commentary from the cast but it's actually a pastiche and it's um it's
Matt Holness, it's Richard Ayoade, it’s Matt Berry and Alice Lowe and it also has like other luminaries of
the British comedy scene from the time so it's got like The Mighty Boosh in it, it's got several people
who who went on to do much bigger things later and yeah it's just great so it's on i believe it's
on catch up on the Channel Four website it will take you maybe three hours to watch the whole thing
it is absolutely hilarious and i would highly commend it to anyone uh who likes comedy, horror
or slow motion. I’m very much hoping that someone who took a picture of John and España on Saturday
can drop it into the discord chat now so that so that Jt can stick it up on the big screen so
you can see how lovely their costumes were. My pick so very unusually for me i'm going to pick
something i haven't actually watched yet which is the Eastercon 2024 catch up programme
Yeah, so so i am planning to spend the next week or so um attending the convention virtually in a
way that i couldn't this week on account of how i was in the newsletter room and on the fanfans
table and and working and also in the bar frankly there's a certain amount of drinking went on
it's hard to imagine i know um but i believe that there are many many many good things and what
you need you to all to do is is message me or in fact put in the Discord your picks for what
things i should prioritise whilst whilst picking up catch up over the next week i thought i might
spend the whole of next weekend just attending the Eastercon because i never actually have time to
go to it i mean i did go to some program items this weekend but i was on them. I attended a very
good program item i would recommend for catch up which was uh Stew Hotston gave a talk on Saturday
night about um whiteness in gaming and about how we can try and make gaming uh more accessible and
less repellent is a really strong word but less off-putting for people who are not white and i found
it absolutely fascinating and i would i would extremely highly commend it to anyone who is looking
for an interesting talk and the other one i recommend is Esther MacCallum-Stewart who gave a great
talk on the history of games and its intersection with Doctor Who and it had lots of pictures of Ncuti
Gatwa in it and he's very pretty yes Esther is waving from behind her four chair fort are we going to take
any questions from the audience do we have time Jt? you've got 30 seconds. All right first person to have
a hand up gets to ask a question. There, Kev! Don't kill yourself Jt we need you. Just following on from the
discussion i wonder if we should rename Glasgow 2024 “a deep fried Worldcon” oh Esther will
Esther will stab you and now we're running away but i think i think that was a comment not a question
kev, Quite funny though. Esther says that there is a vibrant food culture. i mean i think i'm prepared
to say without shadow of a doubt that Glasgow will have better food than Telford. No, Glasgow when i
went to we went to um Satellite the last Satellite convention and uh the food was the highlight of
the convention for me so i'm very much looking forward to going to Glasgow and having lots of
extremely good food.  I mean Glasgow is actually a world quality city in many respects i mean
can i just can i have a show of hands how many people i i did this exact same joke last night
in the fanfans auction so i'm sorry guys how many people are intending to attend Glasgow 2024
weeee
it is noted from the audience that Esther did not put her hand up. How many people in the audience are
not intending to attend Glasgow 2024 okay. Right, Esther nail, hunt them down
she emerges have you got your membership documentation ready. This is very good. But seriously guys i mean
not not so much now but you're probably for the people who are listening to this on the pod i
mean i think it's going to be a brilliant worldcon i think if you like Eastercons and you like
Worldcons when they're kind of doing it right and you like Glasgow which has a vibrant food culture i
understand, but Glasgow is a brilliant world city and and Eastercons in Glasgow are great and
Worldcon in Glasgow is going to be great, it will be amazing. we will be having an Octothorpe meetup of some
description i think i think it's fair to say we have asked Glasgow if we could have an Octothorpe
live session at one o'clock on the Monday i mean we will have we will definitely i think
unless Glasgow secretly hate us which we can't rule out i think i think there will be a live
episode of Octothorpe at Glasgow but um but yes it will hopefully be good would be good if it was
one o'clock on Monday so that we can so that we can talk about the con sorry if we didn’t. Has Farah
gone away because we didn't talk about the con very much. i mean i and i really had a good time i've
had a lovely time i had a fantastic time yes it was great fun and we need to say what we always say
which is that Jt is a wonder and a marvel, and
and thank you very much to and John will remember to edit this back in. Thank you so much to Nicholas
for being our stunt Liz. thank you it's been a pleasure and that was the Octothorpe podcast
and it's goodbye from me, it's goodbye from me, and it's goodbye from me
[Music]
oh yes, dramatic readings, um poetry corner. Retracing principles axiomatical friends yet unmet
follow Leavitt’s decrees, measuring distance intergalactical, by observation from planets like these.
by Duckbunny. That’s very good, thank you Duckbunny. The theme music for this episode was
fanfare for space by Kevin MacLeod at incompetech.com, used under a creative commons
attribution 4.0 license.  This podcast will end at the beep beep